fortress europe shattered dreams
in the interview integration
commissioner for berlin
monica luca
hundreds of african migrants have
drowned off the italian island of
lampedusa
unfortunately there is no european
refugee policy
it exists formally
but the fact is that europe closes
itself off too much
refugees in european waters have to be
rescued
eu law says so far
but that isn't done
formally
but in practice
member states actually have very
differing standards
in greece and sometimes in italy they
don't live up to the geneva convention
on refugees
is a very dedicated woman she does a lot
as one can see almost every day do you
think the italian government is doing
enough
no it's not
that's a big problem
the italians are not fulfilling the
geneva refugee convention
when refugees arrive in italy they are
immediately prosecuted for illegal entry
um
the refugees stay on lampedusa
and are not sent on to the italian
mainland
however the italian government does send
the refugees onto other european nations
i would like to see german politicians
involved in the discussion have words
with their italian counterparts
the ambassador here in berlin should be
called in for consultations
do you think the refugee problem is too
much for the italians
that can't really be because
proportionally germany has more refugees
than italy
in italian in italy all refugees are
brought to lampedusa and kept there
no matter where they land
it causes huge problems on the island
and does not promote a fair refugee
policy in italy
but anyone traveling in italy can't miss
seeing the obviously illegal african
migrants selling souvenirs on every
beach they seem to have got out of
lampedusa and onto the mainland
is that possibly a reason why the
italian government insists on
concentrating the refugees on lampedusa
and deporting them as quickly as
as possible as i can see italy does not
have more refugees than other european
countries do
malta has a big problem so does greece
but the italians don't look after the
refugees
skipped assam
say europe has a refugee and asylum
policy at least formally
it's based on the principle that all
refugees have to be processed by the
countries
should we revise that
and say perhaps that no matter where
they land eu-wide quotas must be applied
that's the right idea i can imagine a
system something like the established
quotas among germany's federal states
that would provide a fairer solution in
europe
each country would have to take in a
number of refugees corresponding to its
share of the eu population
i don't think that's enough we should
also make it possible for people to
submit applications in africa asia and
latin america to enter europe on
humanitarian grounds
they're not persecuted politically and
have no entitlement for asylum
but it's still a legitimate issue
and present they have no chance
those are the people we see on lampedusa
and the european union would do well to
create possibilities of steering the
influx
ultimately europe needs these people
because of demographic change
being this demographic
europe is depopulating
we need more skilled workers
and many of these people have had some
kind of decent training
asylum is actually a sacred right it
helps the politically persecuted first
and foremost
do we europeans really have to take the
idea of a political refugee and make it
into a more general kind of refugee then
we'd have to reset the admissions
criteria
i don't think so it's important to make
the distinction there really is
political asylum a fundamental right
which goes way back and which many
people in germany benefited from in the
past
that's asylum
and we should leave it alone
if we expand it i fear
instead we must create additional
possibilities to come to europe that
would include humanitarian reasons
for me economic need is definitely
humanitarian grounds but it must be
distinguished from asylum
would you advocate a quota model
if criteria were put into place making
it possible to apply for asylum abroad
europe would most likely have to take in
hundreds of thousands every year
i believe we have to establish
transparent criteria
set conditions
and then a flexible quota really would
be the only approach
but i do think a quota would be the
right way forward
so you would combine refugee policy with
a targeted immigration policy
i want a refugee policy on the one hand
and a targeted immigration policy on the
other
beyond that it would be important and
sensible to conduct immigration policy
proactively for highly qualified
specialists
there are all kinds of possibilities
those are three models in all but
they're all needed
you've said that europe could use
skilled workers from africa that's
surely correct
but would also presuppose that language
courses are offered in these countries
of origin
not everyone speaks finnish estonian
german or czech
exactly
language is the key to integration
if we get the people if they come to us
they must be integrated integrate
themselves
and language really is the key to that
that's why i think it's good that the
city state of berlin my employer is now
going to offer language courses for
asylum applicants
tolerated refugees
we should expand that further because
most of these people really
fortress europe is an expression that
pretty much captures the european
union's asylum and refugee policy
the union always thought it's better to
solve the problems that make people want
to migrate in the first place
since the 1960s development aid policy
was always defined as an attempt to
fight the causes of poverty and other
reasons why people leave home
has this approach
where
and unfortunately
development cooperation will never
completely eliminate economic need
and armed conflict in developing
countries
however
without development cooperation the
influx would be far greater
some african development experts
criticize european and global
development aid by saying it would be
far better if african countries received
no aid
then they'd be forced to stand on their
own feet you believe that's a radical
and possibly misdirected idea
um
good development cooperation helps build
up democratic structures good governance
and helps educate people
for me all that legitimizes development
cooperation
and if there is no work the only chance
is to move elsewhere let's not call it
fleeing but immigration instead do you
think we have to look to the canadians
as a model and say we want targeted
immigration not refugee immigration do
we need the courage to say that's what
we're not that far apart from the
canadians
our immigration law has quite a lot of
opportunities for coming to germany
it's
we have openings for specialized workers
for professions with shortages
for caregivers for freelancers
those are liberal regulations not
restrictive ones
i don't think you can compare germany to
canada simply because the german
language isn't spoken globally
that still keeps
germany's labor minister sometimes says
based on her long time having lived in
the us that we need a welcoming culture
not just a new welcoming culture but one
for foreigners for immigrants for aliens
is that what we need
and not only on paper
a welcoming culture has to be lived it
has to be lived by people by
neighborhoods church congregations
muslim communities and sports clubs
thank you